welcome to the David Pakman show I am
Benjamin Dix and host of the Benjamin
Dixon show the podcast the YouTube
channel you could find me anywhere you
find content I'm filling in for David as
he travels to politican seems like we'd
spent a lot of time together you and I
David's audience so let's just jump
right into the news all the pleasantries
aside let's file this very first story
underneath Captain Obvious a report came
out a study actually from three
political scientists from using one from
UCLA one from UC Berkeley and the other
from Princeton that concludes that they
found more statistical evidence that
what motivated Donald Trump's supporters
was not economic as an anxiety as many
people have been saying over the last
two years but instead racism playing is
simple the the three authors of the
study actually caught it
racially conservative views so if you
want to be a little more delicate with
this audience we can call it racially
conservative views whatever you want to
call it the fact of the matter is is
they found more evidence that it was not
economic anxiety that pushed them to
support Donald Trump but it was they
were more influenced by their racially
conservative views I want you to
juxtapose that story with the recent
survey that came out from the
marketplace org slash Edison research
group that just came out yesterday as
well that says that a new poll released
indicates fewer Americans describe
themselves as anxious economically
anxious so this entire trope this entire
narrative that people have been pushing
over the last two years about economic
anxiety being the basis for this support
for Donald Trump I mean you and I most
of us already knew that it wasn't
factual that there was more to it and
that there was most certainly a racial
component to it now I'll get to the
study and the survey in a minute but you
know this is this is important for
several reasons because if we
continuously think that we can reach
this group of voters and we're doing
bending over backwards to reach this
group of voters who we think are people
on our side the progressives think are
motivated by economic anxiety when in
reality they're actually motivated by
their
racism then what are we sacrificing in
order to outreach to them what I mean
that there that to put it like this the
the the racism is the point someone I
think someone from the Atlantic I
believe I've heard Adam sewer from the
Atlantic say that the the cruelty is the
point that's what they like about Donald
Trump this is a feature not a bug this
is not a unfortunate byproduct of Donald
Trump this is what they like about
Donald Trump now that's just my
commentary up front but let's take a
look at this quote from Vox who did a
pretty decent summary of the study and
this is what they had to say about the
study is that quote the study from three
political scientists from around the
country takes a statistical look at a
large sample of Obama to trump switchers
it finds that these voters tended to
score highly on measures of racial
hostility and xenophobia and were not
especially likely to be suffering
economically so there's a lot of things
that are happening here the first thing
is this this this trope this this
narrative that Donald Trump supporters
were all white working-class poor white
working-class people and this isn't the
case there are quite a few individuals
who were definitely economically
well-off he had a larger percentage of
wealthy voters than Hillary Clinton did
so that's the very first thing and and
this you can see this in the marketplace
org slash
Edison research group of survey that
just came out yesterday you know there's
nothing that's changed in the economy
for the working class the working class
we're still working class we're we're
still basically working checked living
check to check right we're grabbing gigs
as we can get them right that has not
changed in fact Donald Trump has
exacerbated the situation he's made it
worse but what has changed in the last
two years because you have to ask
yourself the question if people are less
economically anxious in 2018 and and
they were more economically anxious in
2016 what in the world happened well
what happened was Donald Trump gave tax
breaks to the wealthiest people in this
country and and and that that literally
is the only thing economically that
Donald Trump has done that that could
change any of our
economic factors everything else
everything else has been trending
because of President Obama's tenure his
presidency the the unemployment rate has
been trending this direction since
President Obama you know so this is not
something the only thing Donald Trump
can take credit for rather is the fact
that he's cut taxes for millionaires and
billionaires and so here we are with a
group of people who we said they were
economically anxious because and that's
why rather they supported Donald Trump
in reality that you know in in many
cases it was the racism that actually
drove them now I want to read directly
from the study itself the study said
this about their findings quote white
voters with racially conservative or
anti-immigrant attitudes switched votes
to Trump at a higher rate than those
with more liberal views on these issues
we find little evidence that economic
dislocation and marginality were
significantly related to vote switching
in 2016 so so here's how here's what the
theory has been this has been the
prevailing theory since the 2016
election people said that because this
group of white voters who previously
voted for Obama and turned and voted for
Donald Trump because they previously
voted for Barack Obama that meant that
they could not really be motivated by
racism because how could they be racist
if they voted for a black guy twice
logically that falls apart we could
break that apart in one second we will
but the study finds that even in this
group of voters even in this group of
voters that previously voted for Barack
Obama who moved over to Donald Trump
they had a greater motivation connected
to their racially conservative views
than any type of economic anxiety period
that's what the study finds now to this
idea that you couldn't be racist and
voted for Donald Trump there's actually
a great a great analysis and the
Washington Post I cannot I can never
remember this guy's name Michael Slayers
or something along those lines I'll try
to find his name for you but his
analysis showed that even voters 20% of
the white voters who supported Barack
Obama in 2008 and an approximately 20%
who supported him 2012 they voted for a
black
man but they still believed that
interracial dating was wrong it's there
have been multiple studies that show
this that there have been so there were
supporters of Barack Obama who were
racist and they still voted for Barack
Obama and things changed America changed
fundamentally between 2008 and 2016
everything was racially driven racially
charged the right-wing views
race-baiting overwhelmingly in every
single story every single day and and
this idea that you are a person as a
person if you voted for Barack Obama
Obama in 2008 that means that you
couldn't possibly erase this it actually
falls apart when you look at the actual
data showing that approximately 20 to 25
percent of the voters for Barack Obama
white voters for Barack Obama still
believe that race interracial dating was
a bad thing and it was frowned upon so
so all those things combined it paints a
picture that it has been pretty obvious
to you and me and everyone else who is
actually paying attention that the
racism the racially conservative views
of Donald Trump supporters is the thing
that's that's that that's what drives
them the anti-immigration views and and
to broaden it even even more so it's the
cruelty it's the bigotry it's a feature
it's not a bug today's episode is
sponsored in part by the music streaming
app title which is there to foster the
relationship between artists fans and
importantly values diversity in music
and also supports criminal justice
reform titles 4th annual benefit concert
called Title X Brooklyn is all about
supporting criminal justice reform
reforming and changing the circumstances
that have led to more than two-thirds of
prisoners serving life without parole
for nonviolent offenses being
african-american and all net proceeds
from Title X Brooklyn will help to
support charities like reform like the
Innocence Project like cut 50 and the
equal justice initiative that are
working specifically on issues of
criminal justice the concert is going to
have some great before
including Lil Wayne Meek Mill Anderson
PAC and Lauryn Hill Lauryn Hill okay
there will be a free live stream of the
entire show on October 23rd find out
more donate to the cause and tune in at
title dot-com / Brooklyn that's TI d
al.com forward slash brooklyn